if I ever go with awesome take you to
stealing rent bread hide the bomb under
that roof if Shawn McVeigh has breathe
near you yeah you're gonna be a head
coach of the NFL right troll in Saints
man look how dummy looks in that
[Music]
welcome to Sims and left go and it is
the best weekend of NFL football of the
year divisional round you've always felt
this way yes I mean the last two
weekends I mean wild car weekends great
but this one is the one I really look
forward to it's the eight best teams in
football and I literally got the eight
best in there this year which is
refreshing to me are you saying my
Eagles were in the eight best they are
yes land yeah I'm gonna say it hey you
were the better team on Sunday afternoon
I know that and I'm so sick of hearing
about you and the Eagles I can't even
tell you oh my god just the truth
when you watch all the games on TV this
week and all the pregame shows other
than laughing at bad jokes no offense to
your dad or you this weekend sorry are
also gonna make it all about the
quarterbacks and we get it but it's the
trenches where games are won and lost
and some of the best offensive lines are
still alive yeah so these are the real
matchups for divisional round playoffs
first one Chiefs Colts yeah not just
Andrew Luck and Patrick mahomes it's
it's going to be Quentin Nelson the
guard for the Indianapolis Colts row
all-pro versed Chris Jones defensive
tackle 14-plus sacks but yes that is
going to be a huge point in the football
game
the Chiefs secondary stinks you have to
be able to get pressure on Andrew Luck
run for good luck get in there exactly
right but that will be a key matchup
that I watch especially you that being
up the middle getting into the
quarterbacks face or he can't step up or
see passing lanes that night Rams
Cowboys it's gonna be about dak and
Jared Goff they came out in the same
dress curly and Ezekiel
what's the real match the real match up
goes up front once again your debt the
Dallas Cowboys offensive line arguably
did one of the best in football but Zack
Martin verse Aaron Donald are you
kidding me Zack Martin was the original
equipment exactly right I would say he's
the second best guard in football now
behind Quentin Nelson and Aaron Donald
come on let's be serious he is going to
be Defensive Player of the Year he is
the best defensive player in the league
that matchup will be huge because when
you have a Zack Martin where a team like
Dallas can go we don't need to help you
we
think you can handle him by yourselves
that of course frees up the rest of the
old line to do things but if it becomes
an issue they have to help take that
whole game then mismatches happen in
other words that matchup
I gotta go with Aaron Donald can't not I
was gonna yell you know works right
Patriots Chargers Phillip Rivers Tom
Brady oldest matchup of quarterbacks
ever right I'm already annoyed by it
yeah what is the real match I always
look in PI off football if with the New
England Patriots the first guy I got to
go to other than Brady is Grunk right
Gronk is the key piece for the New
England I know what you're gonna say and
you know if you're gonna say there's a
Gronk stopper on the chart there is
Derwin Jane one guy I would look at to
go that matchup will be key not only
just in coverage to let go I mean we've
talked about Gronkowski is one of the
best blocking tight ends in the history
of football and Derwin James plays
basically middle linebacker for the
Chargers so his ability to even kinder
when James in this match in the past
game I certainly am I think your buddy
you know the run game is where I worry
about the Chargers a little bit but
either way fascinating matchup and the
Sunday night game get interesting who
needs the Saints and the Eagle oh and
you know did you know that Nick Foles
and Drew Brees went to the same high
school in Texas I did they were Austin
Westlake yes I was very ready to hear
about that for seven hours yeah but
what's the actual matchup in that game I
hate to be boring but I'm going up front
again and I think that's the great thing
about the playoffs right now we have a
lot of the top tier D lines and
offensive lines still available it shows
how important it is to win those wars
but your man Fletcher Cox who I believe
is up there with Aaron Donald as the
best defensive tackle they no doubt yes
he says he's about Chris Jones yes he's
a total player I've read he is above
Chris Jones there's no doubt about that
but he gets dangerous Pete your man
crime my man yes big legs big butt all
of that but the greatest combine body
performances in the history of it really
is fascinating but he again is a
top-notch guard in the NFL the Saints
want to run the ball and again just like
we talked with Donald as Zack Martin the
ability to be able to trust a guy like
Andrus peat and go oh no we think you
can handle Fletcher Cox by yourself now
you can have an extra receiver an extra
running moon exactly exactly right you
don't have to move the offensive line in
certain directions I think all four of
these matchups will really
a lot of what goes on in the full game
yeah but you're taking you're taking you
took the defender doll you're taking
Fletcher Cox I am taking Simmons just
said the Eagles are gonna beat the
Saints no I didn't come on
Saints let's do it I don't want to hear
left go anymore stop
let's go Saints I'm George kettle I'm
Trent Taylor and you're watching sins
and let go thank you so much Trent
Taylor and George kettle the second best
football friends I know hey kiddo I
heard you've been trolling my boy left
cold with EMS we the EMS you better
watch it or I'll show you who the real
king of the arm farm is man you better
watch it Aaron Rodgers has a new head
football coach and it is the former now
offensive coordinator of the Titans Matt
Lafleur young coach that was under Kyle
Shanahan and Sean McVeigh at this point
for NFL coaches if Sean McVeigh has
breathed near you yeah you're gonna be a
head coach in the NFL right I am very
disappointed I felt like the Titans
offense was not that great this year if
anything I thought Mariota regressed am
I crazy to believe now I don't think
you're crazy to believe that I want to
make sure I get this right here Matt
Lafleur does have I've always thought
this the potential to be a head coach is
that type of guy I think this is way too
premature though to be put in this
position as the head coach of Aaron
Rodgers and Green Bay Packers and yes to
your point I would argue the biggest
weakness of the Titans team last year
was probably their pass offense so just
because you worked for McVeigh or
Shanahan doesn't make you like the Grand
Master of offense as well follow-up
question right go ahead is the offense
better than the offense that Rodgers
wasn't playing in yes he will have more
ideas than Mike McCarthy he certainly
will that's where McVeigh and Shanahan
and his background with him will help
him but this is what people are missing
like Kyle Shanahan was it all see of top
five offenses with Matt Schaub and Andre
Johnson the Houston Texans okay that he
went through RG three with the
Washington Redskins yes I went to
Atlanta Anna and had the MVP season
right McVeigh built a great offense in
Washington that took over for Shanahan
her it was one of the best play callers
for a few years before he became the
head coach so we're all just looking for
this young guy but you also got a look
at results and facts of the matter and I
think that's where
it's being missed right now they're just
going like you said young McVeigh
Shannon you hired I hope they get a good
DC - but really my big hope is Hedden I
just yeah you're right right I just want
to make sure if Aaron Rodgers and
Lafleur are spending those late nights
in the office diagramming up someplace
sure it could be cool if they grow
together it could be nobody right now I
just wonder well it's just a little
early I want to McDaniels yeah we did
yeah
yeah no I know you played one game in
the playoffs and you had a moment that
was almost spectacular yeah sorry II
Dell Shepherd I don't want to bring up
bad things yes don't but if you could
imagine making an incredible play in the
playoffs it's got to be like the
greatest feeling of all time the payoffs
in general are the greatest feeling of
all time I didn't even win my playoff
game I played a pretty good game against
the Washington Redskins but I knew the
second I walked into the stadium that
day I said man there is something
different around here today everybody's
jazzed up we came out for warmups and
the stadium was 80% full and I was just
like okay we're ready for some big-time
football here in Lavar Arrington and
people were yelling at me and I was like
wow they're mad already we haven't
started so there is definitely a
different buzz and that's just the play
oh yeah seriously so our buddy Lamar
Woodley he made one of those incredible
plays in the Super Bowl and you can just
feel how awesome it must have been to do
it I'd have a shrine in my house just
about the one play just for you yeah
just be like damn look at what I did
don't win that's the Super Bowl I would
say in like the the pantheon of Super
Bowls Steelers Cardinals was like one of
the greatest most exciting games I've
ever seen
you ended that Super Bowl so like take
me through the play man like that was
nuts you know it was like we had a
timeout before and I remember coach
Tyler put inside like whoo we need a big
play you know that's the kind of you see
on TV in the movie like come on man we
need a big play from you'll a big play
right all right coach you know I got you
and then they got Larry fish drove
tallest receiver out there at the time
Kurt Warner can throw the ball yeah so
the best thing to do is it stopped the
ball like in basketball
the guy with the ball so I'm robbing
Russia and Kurt Warner's looking at me
son as he as I went out he did thin so I
dipped out and I seen Kurt reaching back
and I just kind of like Superman
Superman together hit the ball out sack
force foam will break he's we jumped on
the ball there's probably two moments
where the crowd goes nuts right one when
you smack it out and then like the
realization afterwards you know it
didn't feel real at first I'm going into
that game we felt like we was gonna win
anyway so I already have my camera on a
sideline what do you mean you brought a
camera now after hats off I snuck it a
little bit knocking on your jersey just
looking on the field so what are you
doing like selfies yeah yeah recording
myself and I remember uh brick heels
accident seven Marvin you want the
football I said no I meant keep it why
did the hell he caught me at an exciting
time I had a good teammate yeah it's a
this thing I'm still trying to get that
damn bar back now don't get over if I
ever go over toss him take you to steal
you mr. Rath Brett hide the vault
I'm still that room when the Eagles beat
the Bears I was so excited and then I
realized that Ally spent our money on
Chicago so I went back to him this week
and I reminded him of the luck of Nick
Foles and I tried to convince him to
start betting on the birds
thought the barriers are gonna cover
hell yeah I thought the Bears are gonna
cover pal oh man the Eagles have no
chance the Eagles are gonna lose you see
that game yes you see that doink doink
double doink do you see that doink doink
the Eagles again because they won are
going to New Orleans a place where they
lost by 41 points earlier this year they
started off as a 10-point dog it's come
down I'm giving it to you as an eight
point dog Saints are favored by eight
drew Brees at home after a bye heck they
rested week 17 to evil is going to New
Orleans going to North who that City
Saints off a bye so they might be a
little rusty but I like Drew to come
through covering eight against your
Eagles this is perfect yes are you
superstitious alley is a lush she's a
horse you'll notice a lot when you walk
the arrow I was like I'm alone with the
Eagles then I thought I'm like I get it
I just mess up so for the second
straight week even though I told him not
to do it
ally is betting against the birds and
he's taken the Saints okay and you're
probably gonna side what's the spread
eight eight okay I'll give you this I'll
take the Eagles to cover the spread but
that's all you're gonna do sorry
guess what I'm a gambling do they'll
dance on here next week what's the Eldon
you go like this my kid taught it for me
in for tonight yeah I'm sitting here
next to a guy who's doing Fortnight
dances from his kid who wants to give me
the gracious decision of giving me the
spread right I don't just want the
spread good you know what line I want
right the money'll uh-oh why because the
Eagles and Nick Foles
are continuing their reign on the NFL
and nobody can stop them and what are
you doing I'm doing my hat let's go
I can't go anymore buthow this shall not
beat thy Saints and I drew brees I'm
gonna steal all boys role in Saints man
look how dumb he looks in that look
really look better
yeah you look better it's an improvement
good job Eagles you know what's weird
but I want to say they're gonna win but
I don't want to jinx them oh okay it's
all about foursomes peace out homies
been a LEF koe man let's go Saints let's
go sinks
let's go sink he does let's go see the
Saints I really want the Saints really
yeah I can't hear you that enjoy the
games go Birds had enough of this Eagles
crap what do they call them user Oh what
do they call that one I like a
Kardashian wears like clothes for a
company I'm Adam use a model uh I don't
know it's a word like me like no it's
something else it's a word I think it's
still amused I think it's yeah I just
I'm really gonna noun it says a what a
woman who is a source of an artist
insane range you're watching some some
love guys this Kim Kardashian
conversation is a perfect way to close
out the wild-card round into divisional
have a great day hey what's up homies
thanks for watching subscribe to the be
our YouTube channel man you're such a
millennial also while you're here we
have a lot other videos check them out
and then what time there's our show come
out Wednesday 8:00 p.m. be there or be
square
he ruined it it was really close